breath of the wild is still full of
secrets and in this video we'll take a
look at a couple glitches like usual but
dive into more of the secret life of
NPCs with some interactions you might
not have seen before if you continue to
enjoy this series let us know the like
alright here we go
Nintendo put a lot of detail onto
hyrule's many towns but they put a lot
of extra effort into kakariko Village
specifically from the old lady being
depressed about her cherry trees if you
secretly destroy them Oaken trampoline
steens carrot patch at night and much
much more one that's not quite as easy
to catch though is what happens if link
is in someone's house as they return
home
[Music]
oh multiple NPCs are surprised to see a
stranger in their home which is totally
understandable it's a little creepy but
doing this with both the kakariko guards
gives a little more insight into their
life kado thinks you're his ex-wife
Rolla the owner of the aeroshock
returning home which is quite sad and he
surprised Dorian he mentions that he
thought that you were someone else
oh
them is of course pertaining to his past
connection with the yiga clan and
thinking link was a yiga clan member
back to kill him because he betrayed the
yiga clan sort of hidden in plain sight
a lot of NPCs in kakariko are word plays
of very nutritious fruits mostly
tropical such as banana
durian
avocado
papaya
and coconut
did you know that in kakariko in only
they will give you one freebie stay if
you happen to be completely broke with
zero rupees other Inns around Hyrule
aren't so nice
when you talk to Leslie for the first
time she compliments link on how cute he
is link reacts with a pretty rare
animation that's only seen in a couple
instances in the entire game players
over the years have enjoyed getting
reactions out of NPCs while being naked
popular ones being Paia and hestu
but do you actually know how many of
these there are there's actually dozens
upon dozens of these interactions you
probably never saw this includes some
random hylians around Hyrule
most of the armor shop owners koichi's
dye shop
Percy while she's sleeping
and most of the main characters you meet
as you play the game another thing you
might notice is that all the characters
who would take offense to naked link are
ones that wear formal clothing such as
the Rito and hylians this reaction is
extremely rare with other races oh the
Goron shop owner and Goron City responds
to how well-equipped you are for Death
Mountain depending on if you're wearing
nothing for the hot air if you have just
some pieces of fireproof gear and if you
have the full flame breaker set did you
know that the windmill's turn speed is
dependent on the speed of the wind this
applies to most windmills throughout
Hyrule
[Music]
also with these windmills along tanagar
Canyon for some reason are also metallic
and can be magnesis by link it's even
made of two separate parts a upper and
lower windmill
players over the years have found many
ways to explore and Escape Hyrule but
there's one last place that has been a
little more difficult to navigate
underwater while we've been able to
explore underwater partially before
we've only had a limited view but by
using moon jump the Birdman minigame
re-enabling warping with the gambling
minigame you can sink in water using
zero stamina use revolis Gale under the
crowness block and shield surf to sink
downwards and let our camera take in the
views along with link
this lets us see many things that are
difficult or impossible to normally view
such as very deep Lakes
underneath skull legs strange flowers
and even under varruta's feet before you
free mifa
you can ping a falcon bow in Rito
Village or ping a sledgehammer at your
house but nothing is found that's
because Nintendo messed up and
programmed the sensor to pick up
equipment held by certain NPCs even when
they're not visible
they'll only pull these out in certain
situations only then can you see them in
person everyone knows about the bridge
Garden Prego and gives you directions to
places like kakuriko Village Hyrule
castle and even back to the great
Plateau but did you know that brigo will
give you the right directions on where
to go no matter where you are in Hyrule
even if you forcefully push him far away
he dynamically points in the right
direction of where you need to go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's an old glitch called durability
transfer that was discovered years ago
that transfers weapons breakability from
one to another and has been in use ever
since by players to improve and repair
durability but did you know that
Nintendo missed this bug and you've
actually been doing this glitch
accidentally since day one when you
fully pull the master sword in normal
gameplay the game automatically
transfers the base Master swords 40
durability on what you have equipped so
there you go a one-time super easy way
to repair one weapon
oh yeah
weapon modifier corruption is a recent
glitch that has shown off a ton of never
before seen content in breath of the
wild while I won't explain everything
about it since we have a video here all
about it I'll just show some of the
cooler options it's capable of making by
using a single Nightshade recipe and
equipping the magnesis Rune which if you
recall in the last episode does weird
things to your throw you're able to
throw things backwards
another call back to the last episode
weapon modifier corruption now lets us
actually obtain the impossible surf up
modifier and some versions of it can
create the lowest friction Shield
possible in the entire game to basically
surf endlessly on flat ground this is
the closest you can get to an actual
skateboard in breath of the wild through
the new IST glitch we're also able to
create the fabled ice cream this is
caused by corrupting the recipe's data
and deleting it causing it to change to
the default image which is a picture of
an ice cream cone this is actually not a
new glitch when breath of the wild first
released a handful of Select players
came across this glitch by accident but
Nintendo found out and somehow patched
it this is more of a funny trick but by
using Beetle's body as a body Shield a
Lino's charge attack can be stuck in
place and since this attack always
launches straight up you can use it as a
nice trampoline
some may or may not know the hidden
secret behind the Zora you likely missed
Solfege the syllables to Melodies you've
definitely heard of is heavily ingrained
in the Zora
Dorey refers to King dorefan
mifa refers to mifa
Sola refers to Zora
and Tito refers to sidon or Sido in
Japanese Soul fetch conventions on top
of that you might notice something weird
with their theme songs
[Music]
[Applause]
yep you guessed it mifa and sidon are
spelled in their own song Sound designer
Hajime wakai even confirmed this in an
interview translated by Nintendo
everything back in 2019 including the
DLC cutscene where he mentioned sidon
hanging on mifa they created sidon's
theme in the same music scale as mifa's
theme because according to them when you
look through a sidon's eyes mifa is the
real hero
[Music]
foreign
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below we also still have an ongoing
playlist with all the latest breath of
the wild content still coming so keep it
here on Gamespot
[Music]